The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: So let me
begin by just giving you
a little bit of a
preview of what's
coming up over the
next couple of weeks
in terms of the calendar.
The problem set that's
due today you'll notice
is perhaps a little bit long.
But the good news
is the next problem
set you'll look at
and go, is that all?
Because it will be a very short.
Part of the reason is the
problem set that goes out today
will be due a week from
today, next Tuesday.
But a week from Thursday
will be our first quiz.
And so the upcoming
problem set is
meant to give you some time
to go back and re-integrate
and re-digest the material
that we've covered so far.
The material that is on this
problem set that's going out,
it's going to be a couple
more, a few more problems still
related to control charting,
some of the things we'll
talk about today.
And that will be
covered on the quiz.
So the quiz will be
statistical basics
up through statistical process
control and control charting.
That'll be a week from Thursday.
This Thursday I'll be
giving a lecture that shifts
a little bit to yield modeling.
And that will not be on either
this problem set or this quiz.
So that's the plan.
We'll have more
details on the quiz
and I think even some
example quizzes that you
can look at from the past.
But other quick
warnings or previews
on the quiz itself is the plan
is to make that closed book.
But you will be able to
bring a page of notes in.
So you can have a single page of
cheat sheet or notes, formulas,
examples, whatever you
can fit for quiz one
on the one side of one page.
And also bring a calculator.
We will provide for you
any statistics tables
that might be needed, typically
out of the back of Montgomery
or [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll have those
if you need them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: We're
not giving you those.
So those should go on
your one page of notes
that you can bring in.
Or you can just remember
them if you're really good.
AUDIENCE: But you'll
give us like a Z table?
DUANE BONING: We'll
give you a Z table.
We'll give you, if you
need it, t, Chi squared.
We'll give you those tables.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a gamma table?
DUANE BONING: I'm sure
there is a gamma table.
I'm not sure whether
or not it's in the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
gamma of something--
DUANE BONING: It arises in--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: And
that might be a clue.
If you don't have a gamma table,
don't try to use the gamma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Can you put a sample
exam so that we know--
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
We'll try to dig up an example
exam so you can take a look.
OK.
So any other
questions on the quiz?
Any questions from Singapore
on the upcoming quiz?
You guys look so eager for it.
OK.
So today what I want to
do is pick up a little bit
where Dave Hardt left off.
So the plan here today
will be a very brief review
on control charting.
The basic idea I want
to be able to hit, now
that you've seen
what he described
and what you've been doing
hopefully on the problem
set that's due at
the end of the day,
is reinforce the
relationship here
between hypothesis
tests and control chart.
And so I'm going
to just remind us
a little bit about
hypothesis tests
and these different
types of errors.
The probability of false alarm,
probability of a misalarm,
missed alarm or beta,
and how the sample
size plays with that.
Because when you
design control charts,
alpha, recall, basically sets
your upper control limits
and lower control limits.
Beta falls out,
beta being related
to essentially the
probability, again,
of missing an alarm when the
process has, in fact, shifted.
And how do you change
or affect beta?
By modifying the sample size.
So I want to talk a
little bit about those.
I think you might have
touched on them briefly.
But I want to touch
on those and also
remind us of the
definition or give you
the definition of
average run length.
And I think if you've gotten to
that point in the problem set,
you've already read
about that as well.
So let me start, again, with
the basic hypothesis test.
Because remember, all
that a control chart is
is a running hypothesis test
where every new sample comes
in, you're doing a
hypothesis or you're
asking the test
on the hypothesis,
has the process shifted or is it
still my nominal distribution?
So the basic situation with the
hypothesis test, if you recall,
what we have is our
assumed distribution.
I'm going to assume here
that it's a Gaussian.
We'll call that h0.
It's got some mu, some
true process mean.
And what we said is we
pick control limits,
or in the hypothesis test
case acceptance regions.
But I'm going to use the control
chart terminology, since that's
what we're dealing with here.
We pick where these
limits are based
on a probability of false alarm.
Seems a little weird, right?
But basically what
we do is we assign
if alpha is our false alarm
rate, we put alpha over 2
in each of the two tails.
Now, that's based
on this key idea
that if we're in
control, most of the time
the data will be in here.
Every now and then,
just by random
chance alone, even when nothing
has changed, we're still in h0,
I do get an unusual
point out in the tails.
And if we do 3 sigma, we saw
that's about 3 in 1,000 points
will fall way
outside in the tails.
So when we get a
point out in the tail,
we say something might
be unusual going on.
Either something has changed
in the process or I got unlucky
and I just pulled a
sample from the tails.
So in fact, there
is, in a process
that's always in control,
there is this false alarm rate.
Now, another way of talking
about this false alarm rate
is also the inverse
of the false alarm
rate, which is how many
runs does it take on average
before you get a false alarm?
And this is referred to
as the average run length.
So here sliding
back to the slides.
Can we put the PowerPoint
slides on both screens?
Great.
Thank you very much.
So looking back here, this
is our nominal probability.
Again, 3 out of 1,000.
But now if I turn it around
and ask the question, how often
or what is the average number
of runs that we have to go?
Well, it's just 1
over that probability
on any one run of having
the point fall in the tails.
So that's the definition
of our average run length.
And actually, a notation
that I like in Montgomery
is we'll define this as
average run length sub-zero.
What that does is remind me
that that's the average run
length associated with the
h0, the default probability
distribution.
So that's the alpha part.
Where does beta come in?
Beta comes in when we
actually have a shift.
So the whole idea is now
imagine that I've got
a shift in the distribution.
I've had a shift from mu
to mu plus some delta.
I'm going to label that
the alternative hypothesis.
So the idea is
for a given delta,
I'm now actually drawing parts
from a different distribution,
my h1 distribution.
I've already defined
the acceptance region
based on my
acceptable average run
length or my acceptable
false alarm rate.
By the way, there's nothing
magic about plus minus 3 sigma.
If you don't want to respond
once out of three times out
of every 1,000 where
about once every 333 runs,
you don't want to respond
to a false alarm rate,
it doesn't cost you that much to
have a false alarm or it costs
a lot to have a false alarm,
but it doesn't cost you
that much to have a bad part,
then maybe you only want
to respond 1/10 as much.
In which case, you would
change your control limits,
move them out a little
bit so that you set it
based on the average--
set based on the average run
length or the probability
that you can accept
out of the tail.
So that's set.
But now we said there
is also the type two
error or the beta error, which
is the probability of a missed
alarm.
And that's set by
those control limits.
So now the probability
that I would
have thought it was a good part
even though an alarm occurred
is just the other side of
that same control limit
but now drawn from
the h1 distribution.
I really have to
shift, but the point
fell in this part of the
tail of the h1 distribution.
And I declared it good.
I said there's no alarm.
And we saw last time basically,
or a couple of classes
ago, this is also it's
just the tail there
in that distribution.
It's UCL minus delta over
sigma over square root of n.
By the way, this is just
this part of the tail.
To be really careful, I
should also subtract off
this tail, this
part right there,
because I got something
way out there,
I would call it a failed part.
And so my beta is slightly
smaller than this.
But as I've drawn it here,
I'm really only worried
about this part of the tail.
But there is the other
part of a lower control
limit plus delta minus.
Excuse me.
It's still a lower
control limit still
minus delta over
single route in.
OK.
Great.
There is also another
definition of average run
length associated with this.
And the question
you would pose here
is what is the average
run length to detect shift
when it actually occurred?
It's a little tricky here,
because there's actually
two steps.
You can imagine this would
be the probability of not
missing an alarm and
then inverting it,
just like we did here.
So this little tail here is the
probability of missing alarm.
There is also a
definition referred
to as the power of a test,
which is 1 minus beta.
And that's basically
the probability
of catching an alarm
on any one run.
And that's just, it's
everything to the right of this.
And now if I draw from
h1 but not in the region
where I would have declared
it h0, that's 1 minus beta.
An average run length sub 1 is
defined as 1 over 1 minus beta.
So this is the
average number of runs
it takes to detect the shift
assuming it actually occurred.
OK?
Everybody happy
with this so far?
Is it starting to fit together?
Now how do I change--
well, why would I change alpha?
I change alpha
based on a decision
outside on acceptance of
my acceptability of making
a false alarm.
How do I change beta?
What if I say it's taking me
too long to detect a shift?
I want it to take less time.
Change n.
So what changes when I change n?
Does alpha change
when I change n?
No.
Alpha is set a priori based
on my false alarm rate.
When I change beta--
or when I change n,
I do change beta.
Do I change the control limits?
I do change the control limits.
I change the control limits
because my sample size changed
and I move them to
maintain the same alpha.
So let me draw the picture.
Let's see.
If I draw down here, can people
in Singapore still see this?
OK, great.
So if I increase n,
what's going to happen
is I have a sample size
that tightens by my sampling
distribution for x bar.
Remember, h0 is really
an x bar based on.
And so that distribution
will have the same mean,
but it will get tighter.
So now I have an h0.
But I'm still setting
my control limits
based on an acceptable alpha.
But the control limits
will get tighter,
because I've got a
tighter distribution.
I still have the same
alpha in the tail.
And what's cool
here is I'm still
detecting the same mean shift.
Trying to draw down here.
Boom, boom, boom.
So now I've got a tighter
distribution here as well.
Here's my h1.
I've got a tighter
distribution on h1
and I've still got just a
little bit of tiny stuff
over here on the tail.
And that's now my beta,
and it's much smaller
if I've increased n.
So I can basically
pick my sample size
to give me the
acceptable false--
or the acceptable missed alarm
rate or the acceptable average
run length to detect the shift.
And there are tables
in both Montgomery
and [INAUDIBLE]
that are referred
to as operating curves or
OC's that basically give you
the relationship between
sample size, size of shift,
and the beta or average run
length one that you can accept.
You could go in
and calculate them.
Turns out this is actually a
really nasty calculation to do,
because there's no close--
if you need to find the n
to give you a certain beta,
you have to solve
it iteratively.
There's no closed form for that.
Q sum are the
cumulative probability
that's associated with beta.
So there's no formula for it.
And these tables,
basically, or charts
have basically
calculated that for you.
You can set up Excel
or whatever to do that,
to solve it iteratively
if you want.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So
the question was,
we're changing alpha or
changing sample size.
The distribution gets tighter.
Why doesn't--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
why doesn't alpha?
DUANE BONING: Why
doesn't alpha change?
If we kept the same lower
control limit and upper control
limit and I tightened this.
So if I kept these the same
but the distribution tightened,
then alpha would change.
What's interesting about
classic control chart
design is the upper control
limit and lower control limit
are based on the statistics.
So they are based on alpha.
We nailed down alpha first
and then set the upper
and lower control limits.
And there's a really
important thing
that we'll get to, actually,
in just a second about process
capability where then we
start talking about upper
and lower spec limits, which is
related to the notion of where
the parts property
really needs to be
for it to function correctly.
And those are very different
than control limits
but often confused.
And so nominally,
your spec limits
wouldn't actually change if
you're changing sample size.
The part still needs
to function correctly
within a certain band.
So in that case, you
change sample size.
Your spec limits would not.
But what people often
do is erroneously
set the control limits
to equal the spec limits.
And that's wrong.
What you want to do is set the
control limits based purely
on the statistics based
on your false alarm rate.
Chance of observing by chance
or by random probability,
an unusual event.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
For example, in the
problem set, there
was a question [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: I
guess I don't want
to say too much about the
problem set right now.
But you can often relate
things back to the underlying
probabilities.
And what you should
usually do is relate them
back to the underlying
probabilities
and set up the hypothesis
test based on shifts,
questions about there can be two
sided shifts, one sided shifts.
Both things could shift
by a certain amount,
and it might be just
worried about what's
happening in the tail.
There's other hypotheses.
These are all for
changes in the mean.
If I'm looking at some
other distribution,
like changes in the
variance, I could set up
a similar hypothesis test
and perhaps other probability
distributions apply.
Turns out with
the S chart, we're
really tracking the mean
of standard deviation
or the mean of the sample
standard deviation.
And in those cases,
we typically still
are assuming that
the distribution
of standard deviation
for large samples
is Gaussian within
correction factors to make
it come close in setting
the control limits.
Things like C4's and
those sorts of things.
But going back, it's not
always exactly the same set up.
But you can almost
always reason it out
by going back and
setting up what
is my normal situation, what is
the thing I'm trying to detect,
and then look at the
probabilities associated
with those cases.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question, Professor.
DUANE BONING: Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: If I give
you a control chart,
you can't really tell
whether it's a false alarm
or it's a true alarm, can you?
DUANE BONING: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Like how do you
use a control chart then?
Because if I gave
a control chart,
it could be with alpha
probability of a false alarm
or with 1 minus beta
probability of a true alarm.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: This is a
fundamental important point
about how control charting
works, which goes back
to the idea that if
nothing changes, you do
have false alarms.
And if something changes,
you've got a real alarm.
All you've got on
the control chart
is a point that's lying
outside of your normal bounds.
All by itself from the
control chart, you can't tell.
You are exactly right.
So in SPC methodology,
what you are supposed
to do any time you
see an alarm is
go and look at the equipment,
investigate the problem,
and decide was
this a false alarm?
In other words, is the process
still operating normally?
Or has something
important changed?
Now, it turns out that in
an awful lot of factories,
people have adapted to
this notion of false alarm
in a very qualitative way, which
is they see one alarm point.
They look at it.
They don't investigate
the process.
They ignore it.
And then they wait.
They do the next point.
If it's also an
alarm, then they say,
ah, I think something
may really be wrong
and then they investigate.
What are they doing there?
How could you change
your control chart
to actually do what
they are doing?
What essentially
they're doing is saying,
I don't believe the evidence.
The 3 in 1,000 chance of seeing
one point outside of a control
limit is not a strong
enough evidence for me.
What they're really
doing is looking
for a smaller probability
of two points in a row
being outside of
the control chart
as much stronger evidence.
So in this case, roughly
it's twice as infrequent.
Or not twice, but the product.
The probability of seeing
both of those points outside
of the control limit, and again,
not alarming on the first one
is the square of that.
So that's a very
infrequent thing.
Then they say I think there's
really something wrong.
Now, you could actually have
adapted your control chart
either by having it
only signal alarms
once you've got two alarm
points or changing the control
limits so that you basically
move the control limits out
even further.
So you've got to really have an
alpha over 2 that's that small.
So maybe you go to 4, plus or
minus 4 sigma or 4.5 sigma,
something like that, in order
to have that much evidence.
AUDIENCE: What steps are
efficient to find [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: I'm sorry?
What steps?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There is a huge
machine, and everything
can be somewhat changed.
I don't know where
I should start.
DUANE BONING: Well,
I think the steps
that you use to
actually investigate
depend completely
on the process,
but there's a few
rules of thumb.
Many of you have probably
had actual process experience
on different tools, different
manufacturing lines.
What are some things
that you would do?
I'll tell you the number
one thing I would do.
AUDIENCE: Check the screen?
DUANE BONING: Look
at the screen.
Pull the power plug!
Plug it back in!
No.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Check the measurement?
DUANE BONING: Yes.
That's exactly what I would do.
I would always doubt my
measurement equipment first.
They also have failures.
Rather than pull the
process, turn the process off
and panic with the
actual equipment,
I'd want to verify
the measurement first.
So I take it off, do an
independent measurement
of those parts, and
try to understand it.
So let's say that indeed I see,
yes, that part looks like it's
outside of the control limits.
What's another
thing it might do?
Do you look just at
that one single point?
What other data do you have?
AUDIENCE: You can look
at the [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Exactly.
So now you can look back
at the control chart
data that has been plotted
either manually in old systems
or in the computer system.
Track back historically
and start to look,
is there some other evidence
that wasn't triggering an alarm
but that might give you a sense?
And a telltale one might
be, in fact, a slow drift
in the points.
Now, some people might
set up the WECO rules,
the Western Electric rules,
to also watch for drifts.
But that's pretty rare, frankly.
People tend to just use
the upper and lower control
limits in a single
point outside of them.
So you might look back
at the rest of the data
and try to see is there
any additional evidence.
AUDIENCE: The trends can be
incorporated into [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Exactly.
So we could also have--
the point was trends could be
incorporated in the control
chart as well, either with
this and additional rules
or, in fact, other
control charting
approaches we'll
talk about later that
are designed to track or
detect very subtle trends.
But again, the
point would be often
you are trying to debug
the process and look back.
So you are a good
pattern detector,
and you might detect a pattern.
Failing that, I
think then you start
looking around to see if maybe
there's not a systematic trend.
What you're
hypothesizing, in fact,
is that there was a
shift, not a trend.
And you start talking to people,
looking at the equipment,
talking with the
operators, and ask,
did something unusual happen?
The whole idea is you've
detected an unusual event.
Might that be correlated with
something else in the operation
of the machine changing?
So you start investigating
and looking for things
that might explain a shift.
So you go to talk
to the operator,
and it's a new operator.
You've never seen
that operator before.
Say when did you start?
They say, an hour ago.
Aha.
And then it gets progressively
more complicated.
You're going to have
to dive into more
details on either the
process, the feedstock, all
of those sources of variability
that we talked about earlier.
Good questions.
OK.
So I've sort of flown by these.
These are actually
slides, again,
that were pulled out of
last Thursday's lecture
but just illustrate
this notion of
and give some example
numbers of exactly what we're
talking about here with
average run length.
The example plotted here
is the same chart but drawn
a little bit differently
for kind of smaller shifts.
Here we have a delta u
that moves the probability
under the assumption of a shift.
And this pe down here is
basically 1 minus beta.
So this is the
probability of detecting
the true shift under
the control limits again
that were set based on h0.
And so here is an example
where, again, the false alarm
rate was 3 out of 1,000 with
this small one sigma shift.
Now your tail probability
there only becomes 24 out
of 1,000 or an
average run length,
if I invert that,
of about 42 samples
are required before you can
detect that small one sigma
shift.
Now, one sigma shift doesn't
seem all that small to me.
If that's too long to detect
a shift, then what do you do?
Increase sample size.
That's exactly right.
And here is simply
the definition.
What's going on there if we
increase the sample size is
the standard deviation, again,
of our charts, our x bar chart.
h0 and h1 are shrinking.
That moves our three sigma
limits closer together
so that you get
smaller probabilities.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Even if
we increase the n,
still we have to get
more samples [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: Yes.
So the question was
to increase, then,
you got to take more samples.
So there is a little
bit of this two level
hierarchy in
sampling assumed here
when I'm talking about this.
We'll also talk about ways to
deal with more continuously
sampled, even driving
in smaller, not larger,
so that you can
improve detectability.
But the two level hierarchy
that I'm talking about here
is basically this notion
that in many lines,
you've got lots and lots of
parts coming off very quickly.
So in time, you've got
parts coming very rapidly.
And the basic picture
here is you're
grabbing a sample of size
n at some point in time.
Maybe it's a four point sample.
And then much later, I'm
grabbing another four.
So I am sampling from
a what's pictured
as a much larger group.
And so the idea
here is I actually
have more than one
degree of freedom.
We've been talking about I can
change just the sample size,
but I might still in
time only be sampling--
I could have actually
the same time period.
So I'm not actually
changing if I just
modify my sample size here.
I might actually not change
the frequency at which
I draw my size and sample.
I might do this once an hour.
And once every hour, I
draw a sample of size four.
So there's an additional
degree of freedom
that's not in here, which is
I could also shorten my sample
time, if you will.
Because then it takes
fewer minutes of clock time
to get to my 42
runs that I sample.
So I haven't really talked
about sort of the trade off
between these two.
But this is the assumed model.
And you could also
do things, and I
think what was kind of
implicit in your question,
is I could continuously
sample everything.
And these days of automated
inspection equipment
on the equipment, on the
manufacturing equipment,
you're very often sampling and
measuring virtually every part.
In which case, it's sort of
like every part gets measured,
in which case I have a
very interesting trade
off between n, which is exactly
the point you were making.
If I increase n,
then it takes me
longer to get more runs
that would form each point
on the control chart.
So there is a little bit
of a trade off there.
Is that clear?
Almost?
AUDIENCE: Almost.
Because why we don't
simple increase--
because [INAUDIBLE]
So why we just don't
increase the coefficient?
So it's more sensitive
to any change.
Why we should increase the x?
DUANE BONING: Well, let's see.
If you increase, go
from 3 sigma to 5 sigma,
you increase the control limit
and you make it less sensitive.
You have to have even
more extreme low points.
So in that case, you decrease
the sensitivity of the chart
to false alarms.
So in that case,
you would want to--
so alpha and beta are different.
When you play with them a
little bit on the problem set,
it'll reinforce, I think,
a little bit of this.
So again, this is basically the
example we just talked about.
OK.
So I want to shift
to kind of this point
that I was making earlier about
the difference between control
limits and spec limits.
But I'm going to get to it
through this notion of process
capability.
And CP and CPK, if some
of you have run into that
or played with that
yet on the problem set.
The point here is
that once we've
got a distribution like this,
based on historical data
that we use to build
our control chart,
we basically have a
model of our process.
It's a very simple
statistical model
that says it has
a particular mean
and it has a particular variance
in the normal distribution
case.
And an important thing that
we can do with that model
is answer a couple
of key questions
that really come up a lot.
How good is the process?
Is the mean where we want it?
Is the variance
where we want it?
And in particular,
how good is it
with respect to our
requirements for manufacturing
a particular part or product?
This is the notion of
process capability.
And what this also pulls in,
then, for the first time,
unlike all of this, which
is just probabilities
on a normally operating or a
not normally operating process,
process capability pulls
in for the first time
the notion of design
specifications.
Different than control limits.
So the basic way to
characterize your process
is you have to assure yourself
that the process is indeed
in control.
It's operating normally.
No common cause events.
When that's the case for a
normally distributed process,
it's characterized entirely
by mean and variance
or on our control
chart by x bar and s.
So indeed, if the control
limits have been set correctly
in relation to
known sample sizes
and known probabilities
of error and so on,
then x bar and s
tells you everything
about the underlying
process mean and variance.
And now we can
start to use those
to look at where
the process sits
and those statistics
sit with respect
to tolerances or
quality loss functions.
Quality loss functions may be
a little less familiar to you.
Everybody has an intuitive
idea of tolerance.
So let's talk about that first.
Basic idea of a tolerance
on, say, a part measurement
is that there is an
upper and lower limit.
So let's say it's some
characteristic dimension.
We have a nominal dimension
or a target dimension.
I'll label that x star.
And then we have an upper spec
limit and a lower spec limit
that we simply say,
as long as the part
dimension is within
that range, we're
going to call it a good part.
And it meets maybe the
design requirements.
It meets our consumer's
requirements, what have you.
And what we're
saying is in essence,
anything, anywhere
within those spec limits
is equally good and
equally shippable.
So there's no notion
of better or worse.
It's simply on off decision,
it's acceptable or not.
So that's a spec limit or not.
Now, the idea of a
quality loss function
is a beautiful
idea that actually
conforms a little bit better
to what we really care about.
And one could think of
a quality loss function
as this penalty function
for any deviation
away from our target x star.
Now graphically, a typical
quality loss function
that is used is a quadratic
cost for these deviations.
Where the further I
get away from x bar,
I penalize more and more.
Not just even in
a linear fashion
but in a square fashion.
And then I have some normalized
or some constant out front.
And what this basically
says is you really
want to be on target.
So as many of your parts are
right close to the target,
the lower your loss function is.
And then the further
away you get,
the worse and worse things are.
So this really drives
you to do two things.
To minimize quality
loss function,
what do you need to do?
Want to target your process,
get it means centered.
And second, you want to
reduce the deviation,
reduce the variance
in your process.
So with one quality
loss function,
you're really driving the
process towards both goals.
Now, there are questions about
how do you calibrate this?
And there's some rules of
thumb, for example, people
take in upper and
lower spec limits,
you can start to sort of relate
these to some cost associated
with if a part actually
goes out of spec and either
you shift it or not, what
is the cost of throwing away
that part?
That might give you
a point on the curve
and establish an actual
dollar value, for example,
right at those spec limits.
But it actually isn't that
important what the number is.
It's really that you've got
this quadratic dependence which
drives you towards minimizing
both being off target
and the variance.
So here's an example on
the use of tolerances.
And now pulling in
both our distributions
and control charts.
So here we're assuming
the process is normal.
And what I've done here
is drawn, first off,
our in control
process with its mean
and its plus minus
3 sigma points.
Now, notice here I've
superimposed x star.
So this is the desired target.
And notice we're off
target a little bit.
There's a deviation between
where our process mean really
sits and our target.
And I've also drawn
these spec limits.
So now you can start to evaluate
various questions like, well,
what's the probability
not of a false alarm,
but the probability of
a nonconforming part?
And that's easy.
You're just looking
at the tails.
So I can actually
go in and say, OK,
the probability of
a nonconforming part
up on this side is just
that tail to the right
based on the actual
performance I need.
You can also start to
ask questions of, well,
how does my probability of
getting nonconforming parts
change as a function of
how far off target I am?
That's just shifting
the thing and it's
moving those tails around.
So you can evaluate
both of these.
And essentially, a very
nice, canonical way
of talking about how far
apart your spec limits
are compared to
your distribution,
how good your
underlying process is
compared to your spec limits.
Is this notion of process
capability, or CP, and then
CPK, as we'll see
in a minute, also
pulls in the idea of
the mean difference.
So first off, definition of
CP or process capability ratio
is simply the distance between
your upper and spec limits
and six sigma of your
underlying process.
Now, you start to hear the six
sigma kinds of terminology.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
For example, if you
have 30 or 40 steps,
and each unit [INAUDIBLE]
has its own [INAUDIBLE],,
is there a system [INAUDIBLE]?
And the second question was,
for [INAUDIBLE],, for example,
or for [INAUDIBLE],, you have
thousands of parameters,
each of which has a spec.
So what's the quality
loss function?
Each of them is at
some point [INAUDIBLE]
all of them as
something [INAUDIBLE]..
Otherwise, you're not s
DUANE BONING: So you're asking,
really, I think two questions.
I'll give you a really quick
answer right now and then
we'll defer some of those.
So your first question is,
for example, in semiconductor
manufacturing or
in many processes,
we have multiple process steps.
And what you can
often do is have
control charts for each
individual one of those.
You can talk about
the process capability
of each one of those.
And yes, indeed, there
is also very often
the question about
sort of quality roll
up of how quality loss
or deviations either add
up or compound themselves
across multiple steps.
So we'll talk about that.
But the first quick
answer there is
if each of those process
steps are independent,
then it's simply an
additive function.
Where it gets interesting is if
those two process steps are not
independent.
So for example, the
second process step
may magnify or
shrink or, in fact,
even be designed to
compensate for deviations
in the first process
step, in which case
there is intentional
correlation between the two.
So it's not always
a trivial question
of how multiple steps
interact to aggregate.
The second question
is a little different,
which is especially in today's
highly instrumented processes,
there are a zillion parameters
that you can measure.
There's a zillion
control charts.
And what we've been
talking about so far
is a single parameter
control chart.
And there's some very
important corrections
one has to make when you've
got many, many control charts
and many, many parameters.
And just to give
you the intuition,
if the probability for a
single control chart with plus
minus 3 sigma control limits of
a false alarm is 3 out of 1,000
or an average run length
of 333 and you have 1,000
independent control charts,
how often do you think you're
going to see a false alarm?
All the time.
So the quick answer
there is you actually
have to think about an
aggregate false alarm rate, not
an individual alpha
on every chart.
And you really should
make an adjustment.
Basically spread
your control limits
on every one of your
independent individual charts
much wider so that you
don't drive the engineer
nuts chasing false alarms.
So we'll, I think, talk
about multivariate situations
also a little bit later.
Very good questions.
So the key idea here on
the process capability
is simply talking
about the spread
in your process compared
to your spec limits
and how good that is.
Notice that if I'm off
target, this definition CP
doesn't change.
This is purely talking
about the inherent variance,
the inherent spread
in your process
compared to your spec limits.
Your inherent six sigma spread
If you also want to worry
about mean, and you often do,
another measure is the CPK.
And what that looks at is
the shortest distance either
on the right or the left of the
chart between your spec limit
and your mean.
How many sigma
apart is your mean
from one of the spec limits?
And divide that by 3 sigma,
3 sigma on either side.
And so now you're penalized for
being offset from your target.
So let's look at
this graphically
and get a little
bit of a feel here.
And here I'm just
using tolerance limits.
I'm not talking quality
loss at this point.
CP, CPK are actually
just defined
for pure plus minus
tolerance limits.
So what's drawn here is a
set of spec limits that go--
these are sigma markings.
So if I look at, first off, CP
and CPK, my lower spec limit,
upper spec limit, those
are six sigma apart
compared to the variance
of my underlying process.
That's just a CP of 1.
So qualitatively, CP of 1
you should mesh in your mind
just says my spread is such
that my plus minus 3 sigma tails
are right at the spec limits
if I'm perfectly centered.
And as pictured here, I
am perfectly centered.
So my CPK is also 1.
In other words, my minimum
distance between mu
and my upper spec limit or
mu and my lower spec limit
is both three sigma.
So the minimum of
those two is still 1.
So my CPK is 1.
Now let's consider a
slightly different picture.
Here I have my spec
limits different from my--
or basically my x bar
or x star here and my mu
are very different.
My process spread is
exactly the same as before.
I still have an upper spec
limit minus lower spec limit
equal to 6 sigma.
So my CP, in some sense,
my inherent capability
of the process in
terms of spread
is still exactly the same.
But now because
I'm off centered,
the distance from mu to
the lower spec limit is 0.
So my CPK is 0 in this case.
So qualitatively, these
are very different.
Here's another situation.
What's changed here?
Now in this case, my
spread is much smaller.
I've got a tighter distribution.
And in fact, my upper spec
limit to lower spec limit
is basically 12 sigma.
That's great, right?
So that's a CP of 2.
Now, I'm still off centered.
I'm mistargeted.
And so in this case
my minimum distance
from mean to the
lower spec limit,
that is the smallest distance.
And that's still three sigma.
So when I divide that distance
there, I get CPK of 1.
And here's one last example.
In this case, now
I've re-centered,
got my CPK up to my full
theoretical possible CP of 2
by putting it back
on the target.
Putting my mean
back on the target.
So one of the things you
use these CPs and CPKs for
is in manufacturing.
And you also can
use it in design
to get a quick feel
for the relationship
between your manufacturing
capability, the inherent spread
and mean to target centering,
compared to your design specs.
So you can characterize your
CP and CPK and then evaluate,
well, if I make some change
in my design spec, what
probabilities would that do?
If I tightened up my spec
limits and start to say,
if you just even know just a
CP and CPK, you can back out,
because that's all in terms of
normalized standard deviation,
you can back
probabilities associated
with the number of parts
that are not going to conform
to those specifications.
So if I purely tell
you CP and CPK,
you know probabilities,
fractions
of nonconforming parts.
And then you can
start to also compare
how much would it buy me to move
my mean in terms of fraction
of nonconforming parts.
How much would it buy me?
It might cost a lot
of energy and time
to move the mean a little
bit closer to the center
of my spec limits.
Is it worth it or not?
Or would my time be better
spent shrinking my variance
if I were looking for
possible process improvements?
You can start to make
those comparisons.
And the last thing I want
to do with the CP and CPK
is give you a little bit of
qualitative feel for these.
Because what is a good
value for CP and CPK?
Well, the larger the better.
A CP or CPK of 0,
that's not good.
When you start getting
in the ranges of two,
that's often what is talked
about in manufacturing
as being a goal.
But it really depends
on your process
and what the costs of
nonconforming parts are.
But just to give you a feel,
then, for these probabilities
of nonconforming parts and
what kind of CPs or CPKs
those correspond to, just
recognize that a CPK of 1
corresponds to 3 sigma tail
right at the spec limit.
And being a 3 sigma tail
off of whatever my mean is.
So I might be off target.
But 3 sigma out from the
process mean, that's 3 sigma.
Think of this is the
number of sigmas.
And that corresponds to
about 1 in 1,000 parts
falling outside of our tail.
In fact, you can ask it upper
spec limit, lower spec limit.
And we actually know the
number much more carefully.
It's really 3 out of
1,000, those probabilities.
If I go to a CPK of about
1.33, that corresponds roughly
to a Z of 4.
4 sigmas.
I'm four sigmas away
from the spec limit.
You can see I get about
100x reduction in the number
of nonconforming parts.
If I can go another
standard deviation,
or a CPK of about 1.67, I
get another factor of 100.
And similarly, I get about
another factor of 100
if I can get to a CPK of 2.
CPK of 2 means my
mean is 6 sigma away
from either my minimum
distance from my upper
or lower spec limit.
And that's a very small number.
That's really 6 sigma away or
about one part per billion.
10 to the minus 9.
So why do you want something
like a CP of 2 or a CPK of 2?
Because one part per
billion seems awfully small.
And the reason, really,
is so that you are
robust to small mean shifts.
To get down to even if you've
got that small mistargeting
that you've still got enough
room in an inherent process
with, say, a CP of
2 or CPK of 2 to be
able to have a very small
number of nonconforming parts.
So whoops, what happened here?
So here's the picture where
my CPK and CP are both 2.
Perfectly mean centered.
Again, that's the 6 sigma
distance here between the tail.
And we said the
probability of having way
out here in the tail, that's
my fraction of nonconforming.
And it's about one
part per billion,
maybe two parts per billion.
But now let's say that I
actually have a mean shift.
That was a little weird.
Where I've actually
shifted by 2 sigma.
And recall we said back
with control charting,
detecting small mean
shifts at 1 or 2 sigma
are actually kind of hard.
You actually have to
derive sample size
way high to have a
very rapid detection.
And what we'd like to
do in this case now,
I've got still the same inherent
variability or a CP of 2,
but that 2 sigma
shift still leaves
me 4 sigma before my
tail starts impinging
very much on my spec limit.
And so now I'm here at
about 31 or 32 parts
per million nonconforming.
So that's kind of the
drive towards six sigma
is that it allows you
to accommodate or have
a process that is capable enough
that it can accommodate both
the variance and
target deviations.
Both of them are hard to
maintain as small as possible.
Now, one can also go
back and, if you're
given the quality
loss function, you
can also ask if you
have the probability.
So think of this as the PDF.
If I have the probability
distribution function,
I've got my underlying process
with some mean and variance.
You can also do that
integral and ask questions
about what is my
expected quality loss
and do the same kinds of things
for mean deviations or variance
changes.
You just have to go in and
essentially do the calculation.
One thing that's
nice is if you look
at the expectation of
that quality loss function
and just go through
and do a little bit
of the basic expectation math
on that where you split out,
factor out x minus x
bar, do that squaring
and then relate components
of the expansion, what
you get is one component
that is clearly related
to your variance in the process
and another component that
is clearly related to your
mistargeting or deviation
from the mean.
So in one quality loss
function, again, you
can see and relate in the
normal distribution sense
how both variance and how
target deviation contributes
to quality loss.
OK, so just to
recap a little bit
on process capability,
what you've got
is some characterization.
You've got a model
of your real process.
Where it's really
operating when in control
in the best situation.
You know its mean.
You know its variance.
You've got the requirements,
the spec limits.
You don't use the spec limits
to set your control limits.
Control limits are based on
detection of unusual events.
And that's based
purely on your model.
You might superimpose
your spec limits
to be able to quickly
calculate and think
about what the probability
of nonconforming parts are.
But those are different things.
To relate the two, a good
way of thinking about it
is the CP and CPK or an
expected loss function.
What's nice about CP and CPK
is we basically normalized
away so that if I came
up to you and told you
my process has a CP of 3
and a CPK of 2.5, you'd go,
wow, I'm impressed.
That's a pretty good process
or awfully loose spec limits.
One of the two.
You don't really know.
AUDIENCE: If each step is six
sigma [INAUDIBLE] but there
is no-- and let's say, the
real determinant [INAUDIBLE]
you could have six
sigma for everything
and you could still have
zero, because [INAUDIBLE]..
Is there a CP and
CPK for [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: I'm not quite
sure what you mean by tracking.
If by that you mean
being on target.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
let's say [INAUDIBLE]
horizontal and
vertical [INAUDIBLE]..
And each step by itself
would to be six sigma.
And if the tracking
is off, what would
be within that [INAUDIBLE]?
DUANE BONING: So that's, again,
another multivariate question,
looking at how important
it is for two parameters
to be close to each other,
even if one or the other
could deviate.
It's OK if they both.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: And
so what I would do
is if the importance is the
difference between those two
dimensions, that's what
I would characterize
and that's what I would
chart, put a plot on,
set my spec limits on.
I might also still care
about, say, channel length.
And so I might have
another chart on that too.
I have to be careful,
because they're not
completely independent.
But what you really want to do
is get your statistical process
control apparatus targeted at
or applied to the things that
are most critical to you.
And so in your
scenario, the tracking
between those two parameters.
That's what I would monitor.
OK.
So this is just a recap of the
x bar chart with a little--
that's kind of ugly.
A little example.
I wonder if I can just
get rid of all those.
Let me just try to
go forward here.
I think this is trying
to reveal a data point
one at a time, which we
don't really want to do.
So here's an example.
Based on what you've seen
about an x bar chart,
and assuming here we've really
set plus minus 3 sigma control
limits on this chart,
if you were wandering,
moving along, and
just triggering just
on, say, extremal points,
what do you think?
Was this an alarm?
Well, sure.
How about that one?
That was an alarm.
Do you think they were real?
Was it a false alarm?
A real alarm?
Why do you think it was real?
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE].
And those two are
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
So I expect to have
more points [INAUDIBLE]..
DUANE BONING: So the real
answer is we don't know,
but you're doing
exactly the right thing
going back to some
of the discussion we
had earlier of looking
for additional evidence.
So your evidence here was
saying if I got this alarm,
I might look back and say one
of the previous points, hmm,
there's an awful lot of them
to one side of the mean.
And in fact, maybe adrift,
although at this point
sort of looks like it's
counter to the drift.
So there's a little
counter evidence.
By the time I get
to this point, now
I'm starting to get really
convinced that something
is weird.
Because now look at this.
What's the probability of
having all of those points?
Almost all except for that one
or two to one side of the mean.
Well, you could actually go
and calculate that probability.
Sounds like a
problem set problem.
But qualitatively,
you know something
looks like it's off target.
So this is the kind of thinking
that you would want to do.
Now, this is a little tricky.
If you were just eyeballing it,
what do you think a CP or a CPK
would be for this process?
I have no idea.
I haven't done the calculation.
You could go and do the
calculation based on what?
What would you do to
actually formally try
to calculate a CP or a
CPK for this process?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
You'd calculate the mean
and the standard deviation.
First off, you
have the true mean
and you have the
true control limits.
Could you calculate
a CP or CPK based
on mean and standard deviation?
I can give you those numbers.
AUDIENCE: Because you need
upper and lower spec limits.
DUANE BONING: You
need spec limits.
Control chart by itself
never gives you spec limits.
So you don't know.
It may well be I've got
really tight spec limits.
My parts really need to
operate down in here.
By the way, you also
have to be careful
because if these are
based on n samples,
the sample distribution is
tighter than the underlying
process distribution.
So if you see spec limits
also on your control chart,
it's kind of a warning.
Because usually a control
chart is based on sampling.
So by itself, you can't really
know what your CP and CPK are.
And I would be
cautious about assuming
your spec limits are anywhere
near your control limit.
Don't assume your spec limits
are plus minus 3 sigma.
You're really
falling in the trap
of sort of basically
assuming a CP
or a CPK of 1 process,
which is not often the case.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
outside your control limits?
DUANE BONING: Absolutely.
Why?
Here you're having a huge
fraction of nonconforming.
Yeah.
So that's my point.
Your spec limits
may be very tight
and your process
would be horrible.
This is not a capable process.
So normally yes.
What you normally want to
do is trigger on alarms
much before you have parts that
are falling outside of spec so
that you can react to
drifts in the process
before they cause you disaster.
Absolutely.
That was implicit.
I'm glad you made it explicit.
Yes, yes.
OK.
So I think we've talked
about a lot of these.
What I'd like to do is
give you a little glimpse
of some additional control chart
ideas that are beyond the x bar
s or x bar range chart.
There's some very good
things about the x bar chart.
It's relatively simple, fairly
transparent, meaning you
sort of know what
each data point means.
You know what an alarm means.
It relates very closely to
assumptions of normality.
And in fact, by the
act of sampling,
you're enforcing some
of these assumptions.
By sampling within
larger than 1,
generally, you've got
the central limit theorem
on your side.
So x bar really trends
towards a normal distribution.
And we'll talk about
this a little bit.
If I've got long
times between samples,
if there's very,
very short time scale
correlation between
sample points,
these samples are truly
independent measures
of the process.
So as long as I've got
reasonably long sampling times,
each of my samples are
an independent draw
from the process.
The problems are, yes, sample
size, I need n more than one.
And very often I may
be measuring every one.
So I'd like to get to some
ideas or control charts that
might be able to either react
faster, a shorter average run
length, or be able to
utilize the fact that you've
got more data and I can have
this faster time response.
So in fact, let's think real
briefly about the limit.
What if your sample
size is just one?
Could you go to that limit?
There's a couple of
tricky points here.
The good thing is you
have a lot of data.
I can look at every part
and respond quickly.
But now a lot of these
assumptions on the statistics
or the calculation of
these basic statistics
don't have meaning anymore.
For a sample of size
one, what is the average?
Well, OK, it's just that value.
What's the standard deviation?
No, it's undefined.
1 over n minus 1
in the standard.
You don't have enough data.
You have no estimate
of a variance
from that sample size of one.
So an approach
here is essentially
use kind of a variant referred
to as a running control chart
or a running average.
So you look back not
just on the new sample
but some number of previous
data points and kind of
have a window that moves along
or some calculated average
of past history where
I might weight my most
recent measurement
either equally or more
importantly than my
past measurements
and use that as an estimate
for the process average
and the process variance.
AUDIENCE: Does that violate
the independent assumption?
DUANE BONING: Absolutely.
It does violate the
independent assumption.
If, however, they
truly are independent,
you can still formulate
statistics and probabilities
associated with that.
In other words, if your
process data was independent.
What you've got is from
any one point in time,
I can calculate
the probabilities
associated with that.
But if I then calculated
that for my next point
in time using some
of the same data,
I would never use
some of the WECO rules
like the probability of two
points in a row falling above,
because they're no
longer independent.
I can't just multiply
those two probabilities.
So it would get
really messy trying
to calculate sequence
probabilities
using a running average.
Now, that's different
for we'll see
this notion of a
cumulative sum chart
where actually you want
to use the fact that there
is dependence to
aggregate deviations
and detect them even faster.
So you use that very notion
of lack of independence.
So let's talk about these sort
of running average or an n
equals 1 kind of design.
What you'd like to do is
have increased sensitivity.
You want to detect small
changes, especially
small delta changes.
So small shifts are one class.
There's also cases where you
want to detect a small shift.
We'll come to that chart
a little bit later.
You could also have
the desire to not
have too many false alarms.
So you still want
noise rejection.
And one of the problems
with some of these
are you might, in fact,
actually have higher variance
estimators.
And you've got to be
very careful, because you
can get larger false alarm rates
unless you compensate for that.
But the basic idea,
and this almost
goes back to your
earlier question,
imagine, first off, what we're
doing with just a regular x bar
chart but where we're
measuring every part
and then just aggregating in
samples of different size.
So what I've got
here is the run data.
And then in the
little purple pictures
is an x bar calculated for each
group of four sample points.
So every four I
calculate the average,
then I move on to the next
four and calculate the average.
And so in a typical sort of x
bar chart with sample size n
equals 4 where my sample
time is also n equals 4,
I've got a smoother curve
here with the x bar.
And we didn't explicitly
talk about it,
but one of the
advantages of the x bar
chart, what we talked
about was the squeezing
of the distribution down.
Another way of looking at it is
we're filtering high frequency
deviations down to try to
detect a smoother average that's
more indicative of the
true mean of the process.
I'm really not trying
to detect variances.
I'd just as soon have one
signal that just told me
how good my mean is.
And so an x bar really does
filtering of your data.
So if you think about it from
the filtering perspective,
what does the filtering do?
It reduces some of
these sharp peaks.
It aggregates or hides some
of this intermediate data,
reduces this high
frequency content
to try to get to the low
frequency, either drift
or a mean shift a single
mean shift that's applying
to many data points together.
And so you can also think about
these as filtering operations.
And any time you've
got filtering,
you do get at some
of these questions
we were kind of asking
about about how related
or how independent are samples
at different points in time.
So one can actually
go in and have
a measure of this independence.
And if the process itself
within a sample, the points
are highly correlated,
you actually
have to explicitly think about
this and for control charting
spread those data points out.
There is an
autocorrelation function
that's rxx as a function
of the time separation
or the number of sample
points between them
that has this definition here.
If you think about it
in terms of the time
for an autocorrelated
function, that
is in fact inherent in a
linear first order system,
the autocorrelation function
drops off fairly rapidly
from 0 time gap.
So if I sample at this point in
time and I go some time away,
the similarity of those
sample points decays away.
If it were truly uncorrelated,
each and every new data point
is completely
independent of the other.
And the point is simply
here that if you're
sampling from some
physical processes,
there may be an inherent
correlation that
isn't the one you're
trying to get at.
You're trying to detect
long term trends to not
detect very small shifts.
And so you can play
around with the sample
time compared to the inherent
correlation of the process.
All this is saying is you
want to pick your sample
time ultimately such that if I
pick this sample here and then
my sample time some point later,
this underlying short term
correlation is not
what I'm detecting.
I'm detecting again
a big mean shift.
So we've been
talking about this.
Again, what you're
looking for here
is maybe pulling your small
sample out, using, in fact,
some of the
correlation there to be
able to say what the
best estimate of the mean
is right at that point in time
and then have uncorrelated
samples around that.
OK, well what I think I'll
do is probably stop now.
I think I'll pick
up next time, defer
or wait a little bit on
diving into the yield
until maybe mid time Thursday.
Because I do want
you to get a feel
for these alternative charts.
So the charts we'll
talk about next time
include a moving average chart.
Essentially you aggregate
your data and use
that to form estimates of
local means and variances.
And then we'll look
at other clever ways
of using more recent data
and weight towards those.
So we'll talk about an
exponentially weighted
moving average control
chart and what that idea is.
And then finally,
we'll also give you
a little bit of a feel for
a cumulative sum chart where
we aggregate deviations
from the mean,
because we're really looking
for was there a small change
or is there a small drift
going on in the process?
And how do we increase
the sensitivity
to detect that small shift
as rapidly as possible?
So we'll talk about
charts that are really
meant to squeeze that average
run length for detection down.
So we'll see you on Thursday.
And again, while you're
working on today's problem set,
if you want to feel
good, take a glance
as soon as it's released
at next week's problem set.
It will make you
feel much better.